I've been pulled through time
the first season of Loki was a certified
fresh hit and was only supposed to be a
limited series but thankfully a second
season is about to kick off continuing
the chaos and let's be real confusion
established in season one but it's been
a while since season one so we got your
back and here's everything you need to
know before the show it's up to us
[Applause]
[Music]
as we get ready to load up on Loki
here's what will be lokiing at get it
looking low-key okay anyways we're gonna
do a recap of season one a look ahead to
what we can expect in season two a
breakdown of all the returning
characters and some of the new ones we
know about plus who has taken over some
major roles behind the scenes but also
imagine how much more it could get done
if I had multiple variants of myself
hopefully there's a flamingo Naz out
there somewhere sorry again my Florida
is showing here we go okay first let's
recap the first season began after Tom
hiddleston's Loki had conveniently come
into possession of the Tesseract during
the Battle of New York in the movie
Avengers end game this is so many
people's favorite scene I just love when
Ant-Man tells Iron Man is that ax body
spray it's so good yeah I had a can of
the desk for emergencies relax can we
focus please but now Loki is on the
other side of the world and he's picked
up by a group known as the time variance
Authority which looks after and helps
keep What's called the sacred timeline
in order now after that we learned that
another variant Loki a female known as
Sylvie played by Sophia dimartino has
been making trouble for the TVA soloki
is recruited by Owen Wilson's caseworker
Mobius to help them catch her and if
you're a comic book fan you know Mobius
and Mobius has just one of the best
names ever no argument there now as it
turns out the TVA was actually a front
for he who remains I feel like there
should be like
played by Jonathan Majors a Super Genius
who helped shape the aforementioned
sacred timeline to prevent catastrophic
Wars within the Multiverse and who is in
charge of it Pence
the TVA then Sylvie who's had a bone to
pick with whoever was behind the TVA
since her childhood killed he who
remains but with no one to look after
the timeline things started to Splinter
and basically go crazy back in the
Multiverse creating all kinds of
problems and weirdness I really want to
make a joke here but this stuff is so
complicated I will continue for sense of
ease so then Loki ended up back in a
different version of the TVA where his
boy Mobius doesn't recognize him Loki's
all like hey man and Mobius is like who
it is and there are statues everywhere
of someone who looks a lot like he who
remains it could be Victor timely who we
met in a post-credits scene in Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania or more
likely the big Baddie Kang all played by
Jonathan majors and that is where the
season ends bringing us all into season
two if you're still here with me it's
looking like this next season we're
gonna pick up where the first one left
off so ironically enough no time hop in
there LOL so it looks like Loki is going
to be working on getting his friendship
with Moby is back to where it was while
trying to explain that the new TVA boss
is also the old boss and also something
even bigger and better which I'm really
looking forward to because Tom and
Owen's chemistry is pretty fantastic
plus the trailer that dropped in July
shows that Loki is struggling with the
condition known as time slipping so you
know as if the show didn't already feel
like math in your head now they're
adding in science so while time
slipping's got to be really annoying it
basically allows Loki to see things in
the future a future that's not looking
too bright so he and Mobius will try and
figure out the threat to the Future and
also why Loki keeps time slipping
something that's not supposed to be
happening within the TVA I know but we
just saw it happen
yeah now weather this season will
explore the work of Kang the presumed
feature big Baddie of the Multiverse
Saga or how Victor timely may be
involved in the bigger picture remains
to be seen so basically he who remains
remains to be seen
now of course much like the first season
while the TVA Remains the home base of
events there will no doubt be plenty of
jumping around at different time periods
and civilizations making for some
interesting stories and I gotta be
honest some fire fashion moments I mean
the trailer show is located in Victorian
England at one point so there's that and
I gotta say I love a man in Victorian
Garb and from what we can see in this
season 2 first look photo
umbaters ravana renslayer appears in
Victorian dress so she may be there for
Victor timely who appears in the same
time period at the end of quantumania
but we'll get back to her in a second
seriously all of this seems pretty
important to how things are going to
play out in the forthcoming MCU movies
so Loki's gotta connect with his brother
Thor at some point to tell him about it
right I mean this upcoming season seems
like a great time for that but let's
take a look now at who's coming back so
along with Hiddleston and Wilson
returning as Loki and Mobius
respectively we know that dimartino
Sylvie will also be back teaming up with
Loki once again which is is really nice
considering she may have done some
serious damage by taking out he who
remains and as I mentioned previously
gugu imbatara returns as ravana
rensslayer the TVA judge who fled after
her understanding of the Universe
unraveled I feel your sister but also we
need women on the stand Woon me masaku
is also back as Hunter b-15 who kind of
saved the day at one point in season one
and fear not my friends because Richard
E Grant's Comics inspired classic Loki
is also scheduled to return and everyone
loves a good throwback plus Majors is
back this time is Victor timely and any
other variants of he who remains and or
King because as we learned in Quantum
Mania there are many versions of Kang in
the Multiverse and some with different
names it is a world when folks I get it
take it up with Kevin feige this script
I'm reading honestly looks like a wall
in the time variants Authority let's
talk about Fresh Faces now joining in on
the fun for season 2 includes kiwi Kwan
a central figure in the first trailer as
a TVA archivist who knows a thing or two
about time slipping and thank God we
didn't have to wait too long after this
year's Oscars to see him in more stuff
we also know that Raphael Casal from the
movie Blind spotting is going to be
joining the cast in a potentially major
role and Scottish actress Kate Dickey is
involved too as possibly a villain now
the rest of the info on their characters
is still locked in the Marvel Vault for
now but finally let's get to the
creative forces so the end of Loki
season 1 also meant the end for head
writer Michael Waldron who will remain
an EP on this show but he's basically
busy with other Marvel and Disney
projects he's been replaced so by Eric
Martin who served as one of the writers
for the first season so he knows what's
up in other words now director Kate
Heron has also exited with her spot
being filled by directing Duo Justin
Benson and Aaron Moorhead who handled
the middle chapters in the Moon Knight
series you gotta love having previous
Marvel experience on your LinkedIn page
and along with Waldron the man who let's
be real always remains to be seen Kevin
feige is also an executive producer once
again I'm really looking forward to
seeing his baseball cap for this season
okay my friends that is everything you
need to know before you watch Loki
season 2 when it hits Disney Plus on
October 6th it is gonna be a wild ride
and I cannot wait to hear what you think
my name is Naz Perez my variant is
flamingo Naz Perez thanks for watching
and be sure to rate and review this show
at rottentomatoes.com
foreign
[Music]